[Music]
between 2008 and 2012 archaeologists
excavated the rubble of an ancient
hospital in England in the process they
uncovered a number of skeletons one in
particular belonged to a wealthy male
who lived in the 11th or 12th century
and died of leprosy between the ages of
18 and 25 how do we know all this simply
by examining some old soil caked bones
even centuries after death skeletons
carry unique features that tell us about
their identities and using modern tools
and techniques we can read those
features as clues this is a branch of
science known as biological anthropology
it allows researchers to piece together
details about ancient individuals and
identify historical events that affected
whole populations when researchers
uncover a skeleton some of the first
clues they gather like age and gender
lie in its morphology which is the
structure appearance and size of a
skeleton bones like the clavicle stop
growing at age 25 so a skeleton with the
clavicle that hasn't fully formed must
be younger than that
similarly the plates in the cranium can
continue fusing up to age 40 and
sometimes beyond
by combining these with some microscopic
skeletal clues physical anthropologists
can estimate an approximate age of death
meanwhile pelvic bones reveal gender
biologically female pelvises are wider
allowing women to give birth whereas
males are narrower bones also betray the
signs of ancient disease disorders like
anemia leave their traces on the bones
and the condition of teeth can reveal
clues to factors like diet and
malnutrition which sometimes correlate
with wealth or poverty a protein called
collagen can give us even more profound
details the air we breathe water we
drink and food we eat leaves permanent
traces in our bones and teeth in the
form of chemical compounds these
compounds contain measurable quantities
called isotopes stable isotopes in bone
collagen and tooth enamel varies among
mammals dependent on where they lived
and what they eat so by analyzing these
isotopes we can draw direct inferences
regarding the diet and location of
historic people not only that but during
life bones undergo a constant cycle of
remodeling so if someone moves from one
place to another bone synthesized after
that move will also reflect the new
isotopic signatures of the surrounding
environment that means that skeletons
can be used like migratory maps
for instance between 1 and 650 ad the
great city of tio2 ikonn in Mexico
bustles with thousands of people
researchers examined the isotope ratios
and skeletons to the nail which held
details of their diets when they were
young they found evidence for
significant migration into the city a
majority of the individuals were born
elsewhere with further geological and
skeletal analysis they may be able to
map where those people came from that
work in tio2 Wakhan is also an example
of how bio anthropologists study
skeletons and cemeteries and mass graves
and analyze their similarities and
differences from that information they
can learn about cultural beliefs social
norms Wars and what caused their deaths
today we use these tools to answer big
questions about how forces like
migration and disease shape the modern
world DNA analysis is even possible in
some relatively well preserved ancient
remains that's helping us understand how
diseases like tuberculosis have evolved
over the centuries so we can build
better treatments for people today
ancient skeletons can tell us a
surprisingly great deal about the past
so if your remains are someday buried
intact what might archeologists of the
distant future learn from them
[Music]